[Music]
if we're gonna date dude you may have to
defeat my seven of lexus
i'm talking to you scott pilgrim
we need to play now and loud
there was a screening of sean of the
dead in 2004 at the raleigh
studios it must have been i guess in the
summer of 2004
and the producers adam siegel and jared
lebow
who were producers on scott pilgrim
cornered me
and they had a copy of the book uh the
first book which was the only one out at
the time
scott pilgrim's precious little life
volume one and they called
me and they said this is your next movie
and i was like okay and and their pitch
which was hilarious because i remember
this because it's also i think quite
accurately
it's like john hughes meets kill bill i
said
i i like that idea so they gave me the
comic
and um i mean they were like half right
because
i didn't make it into a movie but it
wasn't my next movie i made hot buzz
next
the thing i really liked about scott
pilgrim was the
the metaphor of the book brian had
written this book about
dating life and relationships and kind
of like sort of having to kind of um
be mature in relationships was like sort
of like a battleground and sort of
charting
this journey to being with the woman who
you think you're in love with is like a
tournament
in a martial arts film and i thought
that was really interesting
of the idea of like sort of like
fighting for a relationship
dealing with the baggage of a new
partner all of those kind of things that
sort of like
you deal with in real life but to do it
in a really fantastic way
and then beyond that i also having done
showing the dead
and and i was already thinking about
doing half as at this point
the idea of doing something like scott
pimlin was actually
you know had some similarities to space
in the sense that it had an opportunity
for magical realism and to be really
visual in a way that wasn't tethered to
kind of like planet earth
was really interesting to me so
i i said i was interested and then the
funny thing that happens
like with hollywood studios is they're
like great
this is his next movie and it's in the
trades and i'm
i'm i'm the only one going hey uh do we
want to wait until he's written the rest
of the series first and they're like oh
let's just we'll just
the attitude sometimes of like execs and
studio x is like oh god
let's make it let's make it well i was
the only person sort of saying like
why don't we wait and see what the rest
of the comic is like
you know maybe that would be maybe be a
false economy just to leap right into it
so during that period me and uh
michael cole are already talking like
i'm talking with brian the entire time
and me and michael are just reading what
brian is
is like writing and so i think then by
the time that um
we actually were going to start making
the movie um
there were three volumes released and
brian had
written the rough outlines for the other
three
although we didn't exactly follow those
outlines and he didn't exactly make
those into the final three books so it
was a point where
it kind of like naturally diverged so
one of the reasons i think that the
movie looks so
close to the comic is because we had
full access to brian
and he could literally tell us um what
locations he had drawn
sometimes he had the photos what is this
place
that's totally awesome castle they're
shooting this movie here right now i
went to toronto
several times before we started making
it to see brian
and to do location scouts and just to
kind of like stay there and get the
feeling of it
there are not many hollywood films
that are shot in toronto and are
set in toronto there's tons of hollywood
films shot in toronto dabbling for new
york
or boston or like deep space or wherever
but it was unusual for there to be a
hollywood movie
shooting toronto for toronto and
there was a really like huge plus to the
production
and also to the cast because i i think
more than any other film i've done
it did feel like we were sort of living
scott pilgrim as well as making it
like the cast were all the age of the
characters
and the places that we were hanging out
in real life were very close to what
the characters in the movie were doing
so it's that thing like even though the
film
is like so fantastical and has all these
insane kind of fight sequences it always
felt grounded to me because i thought
well we're actually filming in the real
places
that brian took his inspiration from
whether it's like
casa loma or even just like that
particular uh pizza pizza
joint like you know it was like we were
in the real places like i think that was
kind of mind-blowing to brian leonard
actually that we bothered to really
shoot the real places
can i have you can i have your autograph
please
michael was the only person that i
thought of for scott pilgrim
anybody that was more and i say this
like it sounds like a sort of
a criticism of michael but it's not
anybody who is more obviously
studly and macho didn't seem to mean
like the right thing for scott pilgrim
if he'd cast
super super fit zac efron it's not quite
the same movie because like so
it would seem like zac efron could
handle himself in a fight because he's
like ridiculously ripped
whereas it was more funny and more
relatable watching somebody like
michael be like this amazing fighter
that to me was inherently funny
so to me that was the only choice
because michael was
hot off and super bad like i loved him
in the rest of development
and then obviously super bad was a
massive hit so then everybody was like
right
um and then beyond that i think there
was um
it was more like down to me to cast the
rest of the movie
uh and then there were people who were
already sort of semi-established
like chris evans had already done
fantastic four by that point
jason schwartzman is obviously like kind
of an indie icon in his own right
anna kendrick had been in rocket science
aubry plaza
though when we cast her had like done
nothing i think i was the first person
to cast her in something in los
angeles and then because she didn't cast
has got pilgrim
i think then her agents like sort of
meant then she got cast in parks and
recreation and funny people immediately
afterwards
but she got casters got permanent first
and also
brie larson had been like a sort of like
a a child
actor and even a teen pop star
but i remember she came in and
auditioned against some more established
people than her
and just like like the floor with them
her audition medicine on the blu-ray was
just like extraordinary
merry elizabeth winstead i had seen her
in
death proof i think maybe i even wrote
the first draft of scott pilgrim in
quentin tarantino's guest house
i know that sounds like a terrible name
drop but it's true
and around that time was when grindhouse
was coming out so i had met
mary socially through quentin
and i remember the night the grindhouse
came out me and michael the core went to
see it the chinese
and as we were driving off somewhere
else without a train
i said that girl who played the
cheerleader that's ramona she looks
exactly like the drawing
scott pilgrim what did you do with my
sister i wanted it to feel very kind of
surreal
like that it felt a bit like a anime
and in animation people don't really
blink so much also there's a thing like
michael caine his school of acting
you know like page one was like never
blink on a close-up
it disempowers you it makes you look
weak
and it's true it's like if if somebody
doesn't know their lines they're like
you know like blinking like crazy
so i sort of thought it was a good thing
in this because like you know if you
look at like brie larson's performance
particularly
she's like so kind of like strong and so
unblinking so we got into this thing of
like sort of like
not blinking during takes and uh
and they used to call me the blink nazi
oh no on set
but at the time you know when we'd be
doing dialogue like if brie larson was
doing a take
right before let me take she'd be like
okay action let's start with launch pad
mcquack
that's not the actual title
[Music]
i've been friends with nigel before like
sean of the dead and um huge fan of his
work as well
and there hadn't necessarily been an
opportunity to do something with him
uh in a film until scott pilgrim came
along and i asked him
quite innocently would you ever be
interested in doing a score
and he said yes in terms of the bands
the idea was
that we felt that when there were like
other films
with like fictional bands usually it
would be the same
songwriter and team doing all of them
so like in like say phantom of the
paradise which is a film i
absolutely adore paul williams does all
the songs
and does all the different bands and
whilst there's different styles they're
all like paul williams songs
that's not a bad thing it's great with
this we thought like
it would be interesting to kind of hire
different artists to do the different
songs because then it would feel
properly diverse and i remember with sex
bomb
there were a couple of other bands that
we like looked into
who were like maybe you know like sort
of a younger bands like
the black lips and um this band called
be your own pet
who broke up before we could even have a
meeting with them and and
nigel was the one who said you should
just ask beck beck would
love doing this it's how he started i
thought maybe
beck wouldn't want to do it because
maybe he's back but he like
loved it and then like i said told the
story before but it's absolutely true is
that over one weekend
he demoed like 27 songs or something
crazy and by the end of the weekend
i remember like we went down as nigel
went down to set him up
and was kind of like helping him out and
basically we put
artwork all around his studio in his
house
and he did it with like an eight track
and it was just him and
one other musician brian le barton and
so at the end of the weekend i remember
on sunday night nigel
texted me and said hey we've got
something and then
we went round he had the cd and then we
drove around los angeles in the car
listening and basically that's the only
real work that beck did on the movie
because because
here's the thing is that the demos that
he'd done uh were
exactly the right sound and nigel said
why would you finish them any more than
this because this is what sex bob could
do
sex but bomb wouldn't sound super
polished why don't we just use these so
we basically work from those demos
and it's funny i told back the other day
and i said
do you know how many plays the sex
football songs have on spotify
and he said no and he said he's like
there's like sort of theme from sex the
bomb
which was a demo where you just did one
take has like 20 million streams
and he goes oh wow he goes that's more
than some of my proper tracks
and then other stuff was like that we
cast metric
like the toronto band to be clash of
demon head
cornelius uh japanese artist uh genius
to be
the cathy nugget twins um dan the
automator did like a patel song
and then broken social scene another
amazing toronto
collective did crashing the boys and and
they played on the score as well
like if you ever look at the score
credits nigel just brought in like
you know kind of murderers row of like
talent from broken social scene and uh
beck's band and supergrass and air
and kick koala it was like look at the
credits of the score
it's ridiculous i get very nostalgic
when i hear
summer time by sex for bomb because
it's sort of such a beck song but it's
so
kind of like sort of thrown away and yet
like perfectly
what sex rob could have done and then
like just hearing like
michael and mark and alison pill
sing together it just takes me like
right back
wow i mean you can't say i don't know
how to put them in the show right
one of the things i really liked about
um
you know martial arts films from the 70s
and 80s particularly
is that the sort of work of like jackie
chan particularly
and also um you know early john woo
films
and that and the shaw brothers they had
this kind of structure that was like an
mgm musical
and if you watch a sort of jackie chan
film from like the saw
late 70s through the 80s you sort of can
see that there's like elements where
they sort of kind of got the structure
of like a gene kelly musical
and so if you're gonna make like a
musical or martial arts films
no two fights should be the same the
number of combatants
in a fight should be different every
time there should be some new novelty
every time or some kind of new setting
or something that makes it interesting
so we sort of have to think of it in
those terms in terms of like
the second fight uh with lucas lee
isn't really a fight with lucas lee it's
like scott hilton was fighting his
henchmen
you know like in a in a video game in
stuntman or like the third fight is a
base off it's like a sound
or the fourth fight is not really
between scots
and uh and the x it's mostly between
scott and ramona and then
scott gets brought into it and then the
fifth fight is a sort of bands fighting
each other at the same time
and then you know the final fight is
like sort of scott
versus the henchman and then taking on
the big boss so we're sort of constantly
trying to sort of mix it up
and i hired uh brad allen
the genius like fight coordinator
action director and brad is the first
kind of like
caucasian or western member of
jackie chan's team he's from australia
but gone to kind of hong kong and works
with jackie in hong kong and china
and so the idea of working with brad was
like amazing
you know i think the cars were really
hard obviously there's amazing
stunt work by doubles in the movie but
also everybody that's in the fight
scenes
mary michael may jason ellen
like really worked so hard on those
sequences
probably my fondest memory of the entire
shoot was actually before we started
filming was that
the like stunt training we did every
morning
just working out with the whole cast was
really funny
just like imagine doing a gym session
with like
michael sarah and jason schwartzman and
chris evans
and brandon ralph and mary elizabeth
winstead it was just like
it was very funny
[Music]
how's it going back there like a video
game i wanted a thing where then
whenever there was a connection
like a fist hitting like a target that
there would be or a foot hitting
something
that there would be like a flash like
you get a video game so you obviously
you can add that on later digitally but
it looks a lot
better if there's some kind of like
light source going off on the set
we ended up having these kind of like
light bulbs everywhere
that would be set off in a particular
order so it would be like you were going
bang bang bang bang it'd one two
three four sometimes i'd give the uh
the trigger for the light bulbs to like
um brad or like um
pong zhang his other kind of fight
coordinator and sometimes i would do it
and i had my own little button
i'd stand by the monitor again click
click click click click click click
trying to do it in time with the hits um
it's funny but it was something like
it's a really great effect that
obviously all of those light bulbs are
taken out but you can kind of see
like the hits every time and michael
sarah said
that his main memory of the shoot is
that he said
like two weeks after we wrapped he said
i still could just hear clicking
the flashing of light bulbs he said his
main memory of the shoot was like
and he just would hear that in his sleep
so at the end
at the end of the um movie when gideon
gets you know exploded into coins
we stood on top of that pyramid and we
literally threw like
thousands of like dollars worth of
tunis canadian currency down the pyramid
there was one thing i really remember
about that as well was there was one day
michael cera was incredibly safety
conscious
very very safety conscious as you should
be if you're doing fighting but like
maybe
above and beyond and if he was doing
like a scene with the
with the kind of sword that you see
behind me he would have like a short
version of the sword and he would be
swishing around
with the short version and then for the
effects pass we would get a stunt level
so bringing the long version
and be squishing that around so
michael's doing his take where he's
fighting the henchmen in the club
and michael he's very conscientious is
saying like am i i'm not too close
everybody okay and they're like yeah you
can't you can't hurt us
he goes off to get coffee we do the take
with the
long sword and then in the first take
bam
one of the stomach gets hit in the teeth
with the long sword and it knocks his
teeth out
and the teeth are on the floor but also
on the floor
are thousands of coins so one of my
most surreal memories of the shoot is
like myself and the entire stamp team
looking on this nightclub floor for like
two front teeth in the middle of a bunch
of coins
and the stunt man and also stun man's
weary sometimes things like a badge you
wanna he's standing there
like this full of blood coming out and
he's like and michael sarah
i remember like i said comes back with
his coffee and sees the whole crew
like looking around and sees like the
sun man with blood pouring out of his
mouth and he goes how's it going guys
[Music]
and uh the stuntman was fine he got his
teeth fixed and stuff we found the teeth
what a lot of people wanted me to point
the finger as a blame at somebody
and i remember i've i'd always seen
other directors do that
after a film had not done well and
i'd seen like them say oh the world the
release date was wrong or like the
poster was terrible or like the trailer
was terrible
and i always thought it was like not a
cool thing to do like so if something
like that happens
even if you agree like you just don't
say that
in this particular case i knew that the
marketing people at universal
absolutely loved the movie and in fact
one of the reasons that we have this new
version is because of that
and i knew that the film would like sort
of find its audience
and so i think maybe if i was naive in
any way i kind of thought like well you
know didn't do so well the first weekend
but like
you know people like it maybe it'll
stick around but i guess like
if you're making a big studio film and
you're not platforming
there isn't that thing where something
like napoleon dynamite can play for
40 weeks or whatever just kind of play
and play and play like if something's
coming out in thousands of screens
and it's not like doing so great it's
gonna lose screens
and also i think for my mental health i
had to not read too much into it anyway
because i was still like promoting the
movie
i was like as it came out we were on our
way to london
and um you know like still had to do a
premiere and everything that week
there was two things that happened that
i remember really vividly is one
is that michael moses who is like now
one of the like top dogs at universal
and then was the head of marketing he
was really proud of the movie he
absolutely loved it
and he was working really hard to try
and sell it and it was
at the time maybe even now it was like a
tricky sell like it's a comic book movie
but
it's coming out in the wake of like the
dark knight and iron man
so i'm sure that there's as much as
people maybe
love it now there's also like a
portion of the audience who saw that
trade and said what the hell is
that you know like seeing the trailer
but there were two things that happened
is that michael
michael moses on the monday i decided
like it would not be a good idea to read
any of the box office reports so i did i
avoided like variety and deadline and
box office mojo that weekend
it's like why do this to myself i'm
still going to promote the movie and i'm
really proud of it
so i didn't do that michael moses sent
me an email on the monday morning
which is one of the best emails i've
ever received from anybody in the film
industry
and all it said was years not
days and that's what the email said and
i was like
i know exactly what you mean and i agree
because also most of my favorite movies
were not
successes when they first came out blade
runner or big lebowski
or the thing or big trouble in little
china to name like four there's like
tons of them
and then the second thing i remember
really vividly nearly
all of the cast were in london for the
uk premiere
and you know occasionally interviews
would ask us how do you feel about how
it did this weekend and stuff
and the night before the uk premiere i
thought that i should have like a pet
talk to the cast
before we went out to the red carpet i'd
get them all together at the hotel we'd
have a drink
and i was going to give this speech and
i was going to say hey listen guys you
know
film didn't do very well this weekend
but i'm really proud of it and i know
you're proud of it too
so let's go out and like still have a
great time tonight because like
i know this film's going to find an
audience so i had this whole speech
worked out
because i thought the cast would be all
like as bummed out as i was
and then we booked this room all the
cars came down
and the cars were just like having a
whale over time
i seemed completely unconcerned with all
that stuff and i remember saying to my
producer i said ah they're fine
[Music]
and i never gave the speech now normally
if a studio film does not do well
usually that the creators and the cast
run for the hills
and like just kind of brush it under the
carpet and
you know never mention it ever again but
we were proud of the movie and we knew
that the people who
were watching it were really loving it
so i guess we just kind of carried on as
if nothing had happened
and that was our way of dealing with it
and in in
in a weird way by just kind of like sort
of force of will
it's almost like you hypnotize people
into thinking that it did do well
no why would i get fat bread makes you
fat bread makes you fat i mean the most
famous one and the most quoted one
would be obviously like bread makes you
fat is the most quoted one
but there's little tiny lines in it that
are so sort of subtle that i always
forget that they're in there and then
when i watch it again it really
cracks me up and there's one tiny tiny
line in it that's
it's a bit of adr where michael sarah
sees roxy upside down and he gets up and
he goes
girl from earlier
girl from earlier that just makes me
laugh every time and it's just such a
tiny tiny line and it's so
stupid but that makes me laugh a lot i
guess probably my favorite easter egg
is the catty narly twins and the catty
nagi twins
turn they're the japanese artists and
they turn their amp up to the japanese
for a letter as a little spinal tap
reference
i don't know if there's anything that's
new to me as i made it more when you
watch
films again you haven't watched them for
a while i felt the same way i
rewatched space recently like i felt it
when i was
watching scott pilgrim i watched it with
my editor paul matchless who was one of
the
two editors on the movie has done my
recent film
last night so and i sat there and
afterwards and i sing and i just said
how the [ __ ] did we make that
so it's it's not so much of something
that you feel new about it's more like
so we have to think like
wait i don't understand how we made that
this is the thing
there are films that made like five
times more money than
scott pilgrim and maybe in that same
calendar year
that have never raced a big screen ever
again
and scott pilgrim some of those prints
from 2010 are still
doing the rounds it's almost that way
it's the nice thing is that now
we have this new like sort of uh amazing
and looking at sounding dolby cinema
version is like sort of like to put like
you know the brand spanking new version
into circulation
you guys are so
amazing
you